let's get into this first massive story
i could not believe it i mean honestly i
could believe it it's just crazy
gofundme posted on medium
their statement on the freedom convoy
they say gofundme supports peaceful
protests and we believe that was the
intention of the freedom convoy
fundraise when it first started
we now have evidence from law
enforcement that the previously peaceful
demonstration has become an occupation
with police reports of violence and
other unlawful activity
when was occupational occupy protests
considered to be
violent or not allowed i seem to recall
the uh uh the chas
the chop chaz the autonomous zones what
about the autonomous zone in minneapolis
did they shut down any of that stuff no
black lives matter and these and
antiphon these groups are still
fundraising and making money surprise
surprise they say to ensure gofundme
remains a trusted platform we work with
local authorities to ensure we have a
detailed factual understanding of events
taking place on the ground
uh let me just tell you this gofundme
you you have lost all trust well you
lost your trust a long time ago as far
as i'm concerned i can't believe anyone
would have used gofundme at this point
if you you here's what you do
tell each and every person you know
passively just be like oh go fund me nah
they're bad don't use them just really
really awful use gifts and go
here's what's important though they say
given how the situation has evolved no
further funds will be directly
distributed to the freedom convoy
organizers we will work with organizers
to send all remaining funds to credible
and established charities verified by
gofundme all donors may submit a request
for a full refund until february 19 2022
using this dedicated refund form well
i'll say this
if gofundme is like a payment processor
and they intercept your funds that was
supposed to go to someone i don't know
if
maybe they've got things in their
service like we're allowed to do this
whatever i assume they are because they
hold the money first and then transfer
it but this seems like there's some kind
of
you know deceptive practice here that
they do to take money from you if i say
luke i would like to buy some of your
mental jewels or whatever the hell that
thing is and you say okay and then ian
takes my money and says no i'm going to
give it to lydia instead i'd be like
wait what yeah
how do you do that hey ian give me give
luke this 20 for me i'm going to buy
those jewels i'll be like yeah sure tim
then as i get this one i'm like hey
lydia can i buy that coffee for 20 bucks
yeah i'm gonna give you 20. and then
they come to why didn't you ask for a
refund and i'll be like dude i was
sitting here waiting for luke's mental
jewels what is that this is uh mark
actually mark logan actually gave me
these uh sent me this and a whole bunch
of other supplements
yeah yes
uh definitely make sure you're not like
alert you're allergic to i look over at
whatever luke's got on his side i got a
whole bunch of drinks by the way
there's gotta be there's gotta be
something that the sec can do there um
i mean they've cracked down before on
like gofundme's like if i started
gofundme and i said hey i'm going to use
it for x and i use it for y
um i know that that's highly illegal
right but for gofundme to do it i think
that that that goes into the sec
yeah they they
they should not be able to reappropriate
funds but i'm sure they have in their
terms i'm pretty sure they do
that if something happens in the the the
project or whatever fundraiser is shut
down then they take the money i'm pretty
sure gofundme does say that they
shouldn't be allowed to do that period
though if i say
you know i want to give this money to a
cause they should not be allowed to
reappropriate it it should just go back
automatically refund well gofundme has
been becoming increasingly political and
this move is just absolutely absurd this
is theft this is people being robbed of
their money that they wanted for
specific cause and then they're going to
be redistributing it for causes that
they believe in that they align with
which most likely probably is going to
be marxist leftist ideas and
organizations robert barnes a very
prominent lawyer who was on this
broadcast before said that this is fraud
and there's grounds for a class action
lawsuit here since of course
again how can you say that this is not
political especially when gofundme has
been used in so many different political
ways especially when people were
punished and attacked whenever they go
against the establishment on gofundme
there is more than enough evidence to
show you that this is a hyper-partisan
organization that is not there to raise
funds for any charity they are there for
power they are there for a political
cause and nothing else and they will
stop anything stop stopping in their way
including good people who want to give
their money so if you go to
givesendgo.com you will likely encounter
a crashed website because everybody's
rushing over there to support the
truckers i don't know exactly what the
official uh fundraiser is there is one
on the front page trending that says
adopt a trucker and it's they've raised
213 827 canadian dollars from 2178
people when i try to go to it
unfortunately it's just crashed
so and there's another thing to consider
here because you know this tim and i
know this
as well because i've been running my own
online business whenever you email all
of your customers there's a percentage
that of course never get the message
whether it's an email whether it's
direct message whether even if it's a
message on your own platform there's
going to be a number of people that
never hear about this notification never
open that email and their money is going
to go to whatever political cause
gofundme wants to give so
there's going to be a lot of money here
that gets redistributed in a way that
it's absolutely bastardized and
disgusting a majority of people aren't
going to know this happens exactly
that's right that's that's what i'm
saying um and and it's not going to be
you know a small fraction it's going to
be a significant portion because
whenever i try to send out messages to
to my members it's only a small small
portion that actually do open the email
do actually read uh all the latest
updates and important things that they
need to know
tim let me ask you i mean i haven't
really been keeping up with this but did
you say that they have to fill out a
refund form yeah in order to get the
money back well i'm going to suggest
something anybody that's listening to
this show
um
instead of filling out that credit card
process i mean that refund form what
they need to do is they need to call in
uh their bank and do a chargeback
right um because
there i don't think there's anybody if
it's a credit card though right if it's
a credit or debit card it doesn't matter
yeah they could you could you could you
could do a chargeback um because it's
really it's services not rendered you're
you're paying for a service so i could
give money to the truckers but then
they're going to give it to like some
other cause um some other virtue
signaling cause that for sure you don't
you would never give money to um
i don't think there's many people that
know about the credit card industry as
much as i do uh and the reason why i
tell you that because i've been banned
off of everything and i've had to find
new ways um to to process payments on my
1776.shop and one of the tactics was was
that they they'd go ahead and they'd get
chargebacks in order for the credit card
processor money yeah it costs it costs
you 35 each time they do it wow so if
they pay 21
if they pay 21 for a shirt they're going
to refund 21
and then you're gonna have to pay 35
it's kind of like a an overdraft fee
kind of thing there's also i remember
when um i think it was patreon when they
banned i think we think it was owen
benjamin
he said he wanted to go to arbitration
or whatever and every single person who
got shut down because patreon basically
interfered with like several hundred
people or a thousand people and him all
of them could file arbitration and then
patreon was panicking because that would
mean they'd have to front the cost of
arbitration so it was like millions of
dollars i don't exactly remember what
happened with that
but yo there's 10 million dollars
canadian there's like 8 million u.s
i don't know how many people donated
probably tens of thousands
but i don't i don't know if they could
handle
if that's you know tens of thousands it
could cost them a million bucks or more
it could cost them theoretically around
eight million dollars if everyone did a
chargeback yeah and we should also kind
of speculate why this is happening is
gofundme just doing this because they
don't politically align with the people
in canada with the truckers or is the
canadian government and other powerful
forces whether multinational or big
banking coming to them and saying hey
you got to get rid of these people or
we're going to shut you down or we're
going to make sure you can't operate
your business because this is a huge
setback for gofundme there is no logical
business
reason for them to do this because they
are shooting themselves in the foot and
isolating a huge
public from ever using their platform
ever again i'm never going to use
gofundme i did use them a couple years
ago never again in my life will i ever
be using them
because of just how blatantly political
this is
why did this happen i think there was
probably speculating here pressure from
the canadian government saying get rid
of this we need to stop the funding we
need to stop these protests we need to
stop the voices of the people in canada
immediately so but one of my questions
is and
i want to be fair here
like what did these truckers do did
these truckers like do they are they
slamming their trucks into something are
they
are they
do they got like nazi flags are they
calling for the government to be
overthrown let's let's we got to be fair
okay we got to be fair and call it out
when it needs to be called out these
truckers
they did honk their horns
they did hong kong and you know that is
a capital offense i mean that's that's
you know off with their heads so so says
the queen i mean i'm kidding by the way
they they did nothing i mean it's a
bunch of guys and trucks yeah but but
just even a few days ago we had the
ottawa city councilor uh come out and
she demanded that gofundme stop
this particular fundraising event
because it was quote according to her a
pipeline of funding to unlawful
mercenaries this is the language of an
ottawa city councilor literally making
public statements demanding a private
company stop the voices of the people
and that to me is for sure it looks like
gofundme got political pressure you guys
if not from the stripe payment system or
the the swift payment system
it's weird that the stripe and swift are
so similar but swift is the big one i'll
tell you the situation here
and it doesn't have to do with like
their credit card processor they're
working they're working in tandem and as
far as their views go i can tell you
like this problem that we're talking
about today
we knew about this problem three years
ago um the first time i used gofundme
where my gofundme got shut down was
during the events of hurricane harvey in
2017
uh our funding goal it was for to do
direct water rescues and we're only
asking for like a thousand bucks we
raised like twelve hundred dollars we
passed the limit
and uh they froze the account they never
gave the money um because it just had
the the proud boy name on it it wasn't
because it wasn't because uh
of anything to do with anything else
anything nefarious or anything like that
so i've been screaming about gofundme
for a long time give sendgo has been an
excellent platform um
i uh but they were i knew i know that
they changed their credit card processor
because they were using stripe system
and
they wanted to keep
like funding like some of these j6
political prisoners they wanted to keep
funding like their their uh
their campaigns but the problem is that
stripe called them and stripes said if
you don't stop doing business if you
don't shut down this campaign we're
cutting you off stripe did yeah not
swift uh no they were using stripe at
the top wow and
you know as a business owner
you know
they have to continue to work so they
had no choice but to shut it down they
changed after that they changed their
credit card processor and uh it's been
chill
there's another company by the name of
our freedom funding
that did the opposite so they're like oh
we could we could fund all your causes
and um as a matter of fact they they
stole 85 000 from
my family fund right from my family it
wasn't like my fund um and then from joe
biggs's defense fund i think they stole
a grand total out of 70 000
they stole about like 35 000 out of his
funding campaign so like you have
nowhere to go you have no representation
right you have no money and this guy
comes out of the blue and he's like i
got this website that you could that you
could fundraise on and then he steals
your money yeah that's my problem with
non-centralized donation services is
they're insecure if some like craigslist
you know good luck trying to do anything
with any oversight like at least with
give send go or gofundme you've got some
sort of recourse to get your money back
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you